ok vous demandez pourquoi j'ai mon sac à
dos un sac à dos c'est à la fois mon cv
mon entreprise et ma boîte à outils je
m'appelle yves patte je suis
entrepreneur sociologue consultant
processus participatif et même coach de
crossfit suis probablement ce qu'on
appelle avec ce monde un peu compliqué à
prononcer un slash et si je suis tout ça
c'est parce que mon parcours a été fait
comme ça j'ai été tour à tour chercheur
en sociologie des médias
consultant en politique publique prof de
sciences sociales dans le secondaire
coach sportif community manager gérants
de salles de sport et puis consultant au
processus participatif et en
communication et je pense qu'on est de
plus en plus nombreux à ne plus vouloir
avoir une carrière toute tracée à être
c'est cela dont on parle parfois dans la
presse avoir une carrière sous forme de
port folio avoir même une carrière
multiples à faire partie de cette
génération flux bref il ya plein de mots
pour les dire et probablement que
certaines et certains d'entre vous dans
la selle se reconnaissent assez bien
dans cette manière d'évoluer dans le
monde du travail
même si vous ne mettez pas
nécessairement non une image là dessus
si je devais représenter sa visuellement
je dirais que au lieu d'avoir une
carrière rectiligne nom d'une même
entreprise d'une même administration un
même secteur comme ça pouvait encore
faire rêver il ya quelques temps on est
de plus en plus nombreux à préférer une
carrière faite de bifurcation de choix
successifs selon les opportunités qui se
présentent et selon les les passions du
moment sans plan de carrière prédéfini
et quand on voit un itinéraire comme
celui là ça fait forcément penser aussi
à l'itinéraire comprend très sains
touristes qui flânent rey dans une ville
qu'il découvre et watts chacun de chaque
coin de rue il peut décider s'il va tout
droit aussi si c'est plus sympa de
partir à gauche ou d'aller à droite ou
de revenir sur ses pas sans
nécessairement suivre un plan
et je voudrais qu'on prenne le temps au
temps de réfléchir un peu à la
différence qu'il ya entre un touriste
dans le cadre par exemple d'un voyage
organisé
est ce qu'on appelle un backpacker ou
une backpackers c'est à dire quelqu'un
qui explore le monde avec simplement son
sac sur le dos cantonné dans le cadre
d'un voyage organisé
on est d'accord que tout est prévu là la
destination évidemment puis les dates la
durée le trajet l'hôtel les visites les
repas tout est prévu
alors mon sens c'est assez sécurisant
mais ça peut être à double tranchant
aussi qu'est ce qui se passe si c'est
pas comme prévu qu'est ce qui se passe
si la vue qu'on était censé avoir sur la
plage en fait elle et elle est gâchée
par un immeuble en construction
si la chambre dans cet hôtel super chic
en fait et plein de cafards
si le guide touristique est antipathique
on peut plus changer grand chose
évidemment puisque tout est déjà prévu
tout est déjà organisée donc on n'a pas
une grande capacité d'adaptation et l
inverse les backpackers ont cette
capacité d'adaptation au jour le jour
si c'est pas aussi sympa que prévu là où
ils sont bas ils peuvent très bien
décider de reprendre leur sac à dos et
de continuer leur chemin d'aller plus
loin et si au contraire c'est vraiment
vraiment sympa allawi sont ils peuvent
décider de poser leur sac quelques jours
de plus quelques semaines quelques mois
de plus et pour revenir un peu au monde
du travail
je pense qu'on peut dire que
actuellement dans le monde du travail il
ya plus de voyages organisés d'abord
parce que on sait pas de quoi l'avenir
sera fait on sait pas on ne peut pas
savoir comment va évoluer le monde du
travail
moi par exemple l'école ne m'a jamais
appris à utiliser internet un smartphone
facebook un tweeter instagram
bref tout ce que j'utilise
quotidiennement à 40 ans dans mon boulot
parce que quand j'avais 18 ans tout ça
n'existait pas évidemment et donc dans
la même idée r on sait pas quelles
seront les compétences utiles
les technologies utilisées dans 5 ans 10
ans 15 ans 20 ans
et donc du coup se fixer aujourd'hui sur
des compétences qui vont déterminer tout
le reste de notre carrière
c'est comme réservé aujourd'hui en
voyage organisé pendant vingt ans sans
avoir la moindre capacité d'adaptation
modifier quoi que ce soit et puis il
faut bien dire aussi que pour certains
et certaines le voyage promis dans le
monde du travail n'est pas du tout ce à
quoi à quoi ils s'attendaient
soit les rythmes les tâches
l'organisation et aidera son la pression
c'est pareil ça ils se reconnaissent pas
là dedans se reconnaissent pas dans le
fruit de leur travail
quand on regarde un peu on voit que le
burn out touche 10% des travailleurs le
bord haute qui est l'ennui au travail
touche 30% des travailleurs lebron à
haute qui et d'insatisfaction dû à
l'état qui sont absurdes et répétitive
touche 40% des travailleurs donc du coup
on optique a été de me dire ok autant
accepter cette imprévisibilité du monde
du travail et continuant à avancer en
étant toujours capable de s'adapter
exactement comme le font les backpackers
d'où l'idée du bag pack l'entrepreneur
que je définis comme celle ou celui qui
entreprend des activités sans plan de
carrière définit-elle un promeneur avec
sur son dos un sac de compétences qu'il
ou elle a pu acquérir dans ses activités
précédentes backpack entrepreneurs et je
vais vous présenter les cinq étapes qui
ont fonctionné pour moi à chaque fois
que j'ai bifurqué comme ça d'une
activité professionnelle à l'autre dans
mon propre parcours de backpack
entrepreneurs et la première de ces
étapes ça à chaque fois été comme ça et
les fondamental c'est d'être hyper
curieux et pour illustrer ça il faut que
je raconte une petite anecdote quand
j'étais un jeune chercheur en sociologie
des médias
on avait créé un petit groupe de
recherche avec des collègues parisiens
et donc je faisais la lyre tour à paris
une fois par mois je faisais les retours
en train sur la journée quoi et donc sur
le trajet du retour
j'essaie toujours d'être assez alors à
paris-nord à l'avance quoi la guerre de
paris nord pour pas loupé mon dernier
train est retrouvé bloqué à paris
donc je traînais dans ces deux gares et
j'allais souvent traîné un peu dans la
librairie cayla dans le pré
shop et j'ai acheté un magazine ou un
journal ou quoi pour passer le temps sur
leur tour et c'était à l'époque
c'étaient des trucs de sociologues quoi
j'ai acheté le monde diplomatique
le courrier international le monde libé
et sita et pourrait situer un peu le
contexte
donc j'étais un jeune chercheur en
sociologie qui se destinait très
probablement une carrière dans la
recherche et en même temps j'étais
passionné par le sport et donc je
passais beaucoup de temps aussi à
m'informer sur la préparation physique
la prise de masse musculaire
l'alimentation et c est donc en soi
j'étais dans cette gare de paris-nord je
me rappelle assez bien et dans ses
librairies
je suis tombé par hasard sur le magazine
musclé fitness jal nos muscles et
fitness et pour être tout à fait honnête
c'est pas tout à fait le genre de
magazine que j'aurais même osé acheter
chez moi là où je connais tout le monde
prenne mon libraire que je connais bien
c'est si vous ne voyez pas bien à quoi
ressemble musclé fitness ça ressemble à
ça écoutez body building culte du corps
etc
je n'étais pas trop mon truc mais
j'étais dans cette guerre à bridor je
connaissais personne
il était tard etc et donc j'ai acheté et
c'était fascinant
en fait ce qu'il y avait dedans c'était
super intéressant au delà de la
couverture et où c'est vraiment super
intéressant je l'aï lu d'une traite j'ai
pas vu le temps passer gt gt surpris
d'arriver déjà à bruxelles-midi alors
que je connaissais ce trajet par coeur
et donc par la suite j'ai continué à
acheter ce magazine parce que parce que
c'était intéressant même
donc j'ai assumé l'acheter même auprès
de mon libraire etc etc dans ce magazine
que quelques temps après je suis tombé
sur un article qui parlait d'une méthode
d'entraînement qui était encore assez
confidentiel ici en belgique même dans
cette partie si l'europe qui s'appelle
le crossfit j'ai testé j'ai adoré hees a
radicalement changé ma vie
à l'époque j'en ai faits en bloc pour
promouvoir cette méthode puis je suis
devenu coach community manager gérants
de salles et encore maintenant je
traduis sur les formations pour les
futurs coachs poursuite et donc je suis
tout à fait convaincu que si ce soir-là
à paris nord je n'avais pas acheté par
hasard ce magazine ma vie serait
totalement différente et je serais pas
ici ce soir devant vous donc la première
étape c'est ça c'est hyper
curieux flâner dans les librairies et
les bibliothèques acheter des magazines
des livres que vous n'auriez pas pensé
lire regarder les reportages que vous
n'aurez pas pensé regarder surfer sur
internet de liens en liens intégrés vous
savez jamais sur quoi vous allez tomber
et quel impact ça aura sur votre vie ça
c'était la première étape la deuxième
étape c'est de suivre toujours ce qui
nous anime le plus en fait pour savoir
vers quoi bifurquer j'utilise un truc
simple c'est que je me laisse toujours
guidé par ce que je ne peux pas
contrôler ça peut être une activité qui
me tient éveillés tard le soir alors que
je sais que je vais me lever tôt le
lendemain matin
ça peut être une lecture qui me met en
retard mais que j'ai pas envie d'arrêter
parce que ça ça m'intéresse vraiment où
une conférence avec elle j'ai vraiment
envie d'allier un soir alors que je sais
pas j'ai plein d'autres choses à faire
ce soir là où je suis fatigué ou quoi
bref c'est vraiment ce qui prend le
dessus sur le reste
sans qu'on puisse le contrôler c'est
toujours ça que j'essaye à terme de
transformer en activité professionnelle
et je pense que au moins trois avantages
à fonctionner comme ça le premier c'est
évident c'est que c'est là dessus qu'on
peut être le plus productif ou la plus
productive quoi c'est logique puisque
c'est ce qui nous passionne on peut
travailler plus plus longtemps en plus
intensément avec moins de moins de
distractions là dessus mais c'est aussi
je pense là dessus qu'on peut être le
plus authentique qu'on peut réellement
avoir l'impression d'être soi même
d'être de pouvoir pleinement s'exprimer
quoi peut-être que certaines et certains
d'entre vous dans la salle ici on
l'impression dans leur boulot la journée
de d'occuper un poste comme on dit ou de
jouer un rôle ou de répondre aux
attentes d'une hiérarchie d'une
direction
et puis le soir quand vous rentrez chez
vous là vous êtes pris par cette passion
est là vous avez l'impression d'être
pleinement vous même de pouvoir
réellement pleinement vous exprimer que
ce soit en rédigeant un blog en publiant
des recettes de cuisine en coachant des
amis en faisant de la photo que importe
là vous avez l'impression d'être
pleinement vous même et petites
parenthèses il ya un auteur qui est
assez rarement lu par les futurs
entrepreneurs par lé coach en
développement personnel etc qui pourtant
intéressant à ce niveau là c'est karl
marx
karl marx ils définissent elles allient
nation précisément comme le fait de ne
pas se reconnaître dans le fruit de son
travail dans les déserts proprié il
écrivait l'ouvrier aliéné se sent dans
son travail en dehors de soi c'est à
dire en dehors de lui-même et donc je
suis assez convaincu que le fait de
développer des activités
professionnelles dans un domaine qui
nous passionne vraiment ça nous permet
de nous reconnecter à nous même si on
veut et de ne pas être aliénés dans son
travail puis troisième avantage c'est
que ça permet de faire les choses
au début juste par passion et quand je
dis juste par passion ça veut dire sans
gagner tout de suite de l'argent sans
essayer tout de suite que ça soit
rentable ça à chaque fois comme ça que
j'ai fait j'ai d'abord entraîné un pote
puis quelques potes avant de devenir un
coach rémunérés je me suis entraînée
dans je me suis impliqué pendant des
processus et des projets participatifs
et collaboratif
parce que ça m'intéressait juste par
plaisir parce que ça me passionnait
avant de développer des activités
professionnelles là dedans donc je pense
qu'au début ça peut vraiment être bien
pour se lancer pour bifurquer juste
faire les choses par passion par plaisir
sans chercher tout de suite la
rentabilité mais juste pour emmagasiner
des des compétences et des expériences
que vous pouvez rajouter dans votre sac
à dos et qui sont utiles pour la suite
quoi c'était la deuxième étape
troisième étape ça consiste à profiter
au maximum de toute l'information
disponible et pour ça on est dans une
époque formidable
un clic gratuitement et on a accès à des
tonnes d'informations et de
connaissances donc il faut essayer s'en
servir pour le plus vite possible
devenir un véritable petit experts dans
ce domaine qui nous passionne d'autant
plus que la plupart des domaines dans
lesquels des entrepreneurs font comme ça
des bifurcations ou enfin des
reconversions professionnelles sont des
domaines dans lesquels n'y a pas de
diplôme
donc finalement votre légitimité elle
viendra des connaissances des
compétences que vous aurez pu acquérir
par vous même
donc autant en profiter et puis
inversément
c'est bien aussi d'utiliser il faut je
pense utiliser tous ses moyens
d'information pour vous faire connaître
pour faire connaître ce que vous faites
pour être connu et reconnu pour ça vous
pouvez faire les meilleurs lasagnes
vegan du monde
si vous êtes le seul à le savoir ça vous
aidera pas à développer votre activité
évident
du coup utiliser tous ses réseaux
possibles et imaginables et mon conseil
c'est de faire le plus vite possible
croyez moi la probabilité qu on vous
pique votre idée qui est en train
d'émerger là est en fait tout tout tout
tout petit par rapport à la probabilité
que vous que des opportunités se
présentent quand vous allez commencer à
communiquer dessus donc communiquer
dessus à fond 4e étape
il faut prendre conscience de son sac à
dos vous avez toutes et tous un sac à
dos comme celui là même s'il est virtuel
on va dire chez certains un sac à dos
rempli de compétences et d'expérience
que vous pouvez mettre au service de
projets qui vous passionne et donc vous
pourriez vivre
je veux juste en prendre conscience et
donc je vous invite à prendre le temps à
la pala maintenant mais dans les jours
qui viennent à prendre le temps pour
réfléchir à toutes les compétences que
vous avez pu acquérir au fil de votre
parcours
ce soit dans vos études dans votre job
en terre et or et actuel dans les
activités de loisirs tout toute
compétence peut être utile comme ça pour
être mise au service de projets qui vous
passionne et vers lesquelles vous
voudrez alliés et au plus vous allez
arriver à développer vos activités
juste à l'intersection entre vos
compétences c'est-à-dire ce que vous
savez faire vos expériences ce que vous
avez déjà fait et vos passions ce que
vous aimez faire au mieux ça marchera et
la 5e et dernière étape qui est celle
qui fait probablement le plus la
différence entre celles et ceux qui ont
une idée qui vont se lancer un jour mais
pas maintenant et celles et ceux qui se
lancent et qui vivent de leur projet
c'est de se lancer avant des prêts bien
vous savez quoi
on n'est jamais prêt en fait on n'est
jamais prêt pour quitter même
progressivement en bouleau salariés est
assurée pour se lancer dans l'inconnu
l entreprenariat et donc c'est c'est
précisément en ce sens qu'on arriverait
à être prêt alors évidemment je vous
vois venir les questions je vous dirai
pas ça si vous me disiez que vous
vouliez vous lancer dans la chirurgie
cardiaque ou dans la physique nucléaire
ok là je vous dirais plutôt mieux vaut
prendre son temps et dessus à son
diplôme etc
mais comme je voulais dit la plupart des
secteurs dans lesquels des entrepreneurs
font comme ça des reconversions et des
bifurcations professionnels sont les
secteurs dans laquelle il n'y a pas de
diplôme
il n'y a pas d'accès à la profession
parce qu'en fait le degré de dangerosité
ou de gravité si on fait une erreur
n'est pas immense donc allez-y
lancez-vous testé expérimenté fait des
erreurs et fait en sorte que chacune de
ces erreurs évidemment vous avez des
avancées et quand vous évoluerez comme
ça dans dans le monde du travail
simplement avec un sac à dos rempli de
compétences et d'expérience à mettre au
service de projets qui vous passionne et
dont vous pourriez vivre
je pense que vous allez vous rendre
compte que le bag pack entrepreneur peut
être service d'une mission plus grande
d'ailleurs la plupart de celles et ceux
qui vivent comme ça sont assez proches
de l'entrepreneuriat social de
l'économie collaborative des projets en
transition bref ils ou elles portent des
projets qui sont toujours très positif
qui apporte quelque chose de positif à
la collectivité en fait évidemment
entendu personne qui me disaient j'ai
envie de quitter ce boulot que j'ai un
pas qui m'ennuie de stars pour me lancer
dans ma passion ce truc qui m'anime
et ces ventres des clopes ou vendre du
pétrole ou créer des pesticides ipl riga
lasse jamais personne qui dit ça en fait
ça c'est ce que les gens font dans le
boulot qu'ils ont envie de quitter
précisément et donc du coup je suis
vraiment persuadé que le fait d'être
backpack entrepreneur permet donc d'être
au service d'une mission plus grande et
de suivre un but autre que faire gagner
de l'argent à des actionnaires quoi et
si je devais résumer ça je dirais que du
coup voilà je ne suis pas au service de
la mission de l'entreprise
c'est mon entreprise ça qui est au
service de la mission que je me donne
moi en tant que citoyen et si ça vous
parle
si vous avez vous aussi envie de vous
lancer là dedans de vivre de vos projets
avec un sac à dos rempli de compétences
et d'expériences et de mener des projets
qui vous passionne vraiment est
d'arriver en vivre bah je vous invite à
vous lancer évidemment et n'oubliez pas
celui toujours hyper curieux suivaient
toujours ce qui vous anime le plus
profité tous les moyens du cas
d'informations possible prenez
conscience de votre sac à dos évidemment
lancez-vous avant d'être prêt merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]